five factors to selling ad space and
setting prices so I got a great question
for my YouTube viewers love you guys
able Abe studios who wrote in to say
great video Evans it seems like every
question I search for an answer for one
of your videos pops up very cool my
question now is if you we're developing
an art photography magazine how would
you go about pricing ad spaces would it
be the size of the ad the frequency the
creative development or something else
go so able Abe and follow you people out
there one in the certain magazine here
are the five factors you need to look at
when you're setting your ad prices and
trying to sell them
number one is circulation this is going
to be the first question everybody asks
you how many people read your magazine
right if it's a national magazine and
you're selling a full-page ad that could
be a quarter of a million dollars if
you're much smaller magazine that could
be ten thousand dollars or two thousand
dollars you got to know how many people
are actually reading your magazine and
the advertisers again it seemed that the
first thing they asked you for number
two is demographics who is actually
reading the magazine who is your
audience and the more specific and niche
and defined it is the easier it is to
charge more money so for example if you
had a magazine that was trying to reach
really hard to access people say it was
CEOs of Fortune 500 companies that's who
was reading the magazine while your
circulation is getting really small
right there's only 500 people maximum
who could read it because it's a fortune
500 but that's a really targeted select
group of people that people would pay
big money advertising would really want
to get in there and spend their cash to
reach those people so the more clearly
defined your demographics are the more
you can say with the age the sex the the
interests and hobbies and and more
demographic information the more you can
throw out there the better it is and the
harder those people are to reach the
more you can increase your prices number
three is the size of the ad so how much
ad space are we talking about usually go
by percentage of the page so if it's a
full page maybe that's $10,000 if it's a
half page maybe that's $6,000 right the
more space that they want the more you
charge for it number four is frequency
how often is your magazine coming out
in how many editions is the advertiser
going to be advertising in it for so for
example if your magazine comes out once
a month are they just buying in for that
once you know they only buy for one ad
spot in that first edition and that's it
or are they going to be doing it every
month for six months or 12 months right
if it's a one-off deal then you might
sell an ad space for $2,000 but if it's
a commitment to do this for six months
and you could sell that same ad space
for discounted price say $1,500 because
it committed to you for a number of
months and you don't have to go out and
sell that spot to somebody else and
number five is positioning where do they
get the app most advertisers want to be
either on the back cover on the inside
of the front cover or as close to the
front as possible and the rates can go
up the closer to the front so if I'm
getting a an inside page on a national
magazine that could cost me half a
million dollars but that same page for
the Rinne will cost a lot less so you
can sell your rates depending on where
they are in the positioning other
magazine so the top five things and look
at our circulation demographics size
frequency and positioning now the
magazine industry is super traditional a
kind of boring honestly and it's easy to
find out what the rates are of your
competition so honestly what I look at
is try to find somebody who has a
similar magazine similar demographic
similar size and see what they're
charging you know you can get those
rates and charge something similar right
you want to be cost competitive now on
top of that what I'd say is if you want
to have a lot of success with this you
got to think a little bit outside the
box you've got to know what everybody
else is charging charge something
similar but then over deliver on the
value find some bonuses that you can
throw in there because most of the time
the advertisers in a magazine
they're left to come up with everything
themselves right and and the the
magazine does nothing to really help
that advertiser out and this is across a
lot of different platforms an example is
I had these DVDs that I was selling on
the Shopping Channel and you know we
passed all the criteria we got on the
Shopping Channel and we were left to
come up with the pitch ourselves they
didn't train us on what we needed to say
we need to have with us how to
make an effective sales pitch and we
probably could have sold a lot more if
we had that training instead of leaving
us to figure out ourselves so this is
going to be important especially for
first-time advertisers they're coming
your magazine they're not quite sure you
know what ads are going to work what's
not going to work who's going to reach
your audience the best support that
right help them help them with their
design tell them what will work and what
won't work interview them and have bonus
features of them in your magazine and
have stories about them instead of just
the ads think about how you can help
them on social media how you can plug
them maybe you put an ad up on your
website version as well maybe you take a
percentage of the sales that come
through the magazine you have a special
offer or coupon code that comes through
the magazine and that's how you get paid
instead of just a regular traditional
rates show me that you care about my
business showing me that I'm more than
just dollar signs for you and if you can
put that extra effort in and show those
little bonus improvements there you're
not taking the traditional advertising
model that all the other magazines out
there are doing you show me that I'm
getting results right if I'm getting
results from your magazine I'm going to
want to advertise in there more I'm
going to tell my friends about this
awesome magazine I'm getting huge
leverage from when everybody else is
failing me so I'd encourage you to
really think how can I make sure that
every advertiser that comes to me gets
an amazing result for their budget and
that makes them want to come back over
and over and over and over and over
again and that experience is so much
more important than just worrying about
those five factors and how you're going
to apply it to your pricing so hopefully
I answers your question continue to
believe if you guys like this video you
want to see more just like it subscribe
to the channel thank you so much for
watching I'll see you soon hi every
Kelly English here with mermaids on T TV
are you on evans newsletter subscription
if not you should be I read every single
one and you should too
ciao
you